Колись на львівському "Електроні" виробляли
перші у Радянському Союзі кольорові телевізори.
А сьогодні в орендованому приміщенні заводу
інженери IT-компанії N-iX
тестують симулятор для тренування квотербеків -
нападників в американському футболі.
Система, що працює на основі віртуальної реальності,
дозволяє економити час
і робить підготовку футболістів більш безпечною.
Команда травмується під час тренувань,
і відповідно це дає ризики по матчу. І квотербек травмується.
Тому цей симулятор також зменшує
кількість травм під час тренування квотербека.
Аналогів у світі симулятор не має, каже Андрій Павлів.
Програмісти компанії працювали над ним два роки.
Розробляли "з нуля" - для замовника зі Сполучених Штатів.
Як і більшість українських IT-компаній,
N-iX працює переважно на експорт.
Створює програмне забезпечення для різних галузей -
від телекомунікацій до медицини.
На глобальному ринку конкурують не завдяки низьким цінам,
а за рахунок якості. Адже українських програмістів
цінують у всьому світі - як фахівців, що вміють і люблять
вирішувати складні задачі.
Можливо, це навіть специфіка українців,
що вони живуть постійно в якійсь кризі,
вони постійно мають вирішувати проблеми,
це впливає на те, як вони працюють.
Ти можеш почути про це в Лондоні, в Каліфорнії, в Нью-Йорку.
В дуже багатьох проектах,
Де є щось складне - там точно є українські інженери.
Коли Андрій Павлів у 2002 році заснував компанію,
це був класичний стартап з трьох осіб.
Зараз на N-iX працює майже тисяча фахівців,
а компанія має представництва у Швеції,
США, Болгарії, Польщі та Білорусі.
Справжній прорив почався у 2014-му -
лише за три роки львівська IT-компанія
виросла на 330 відсотків.
Цьому N-iX завдячує глобальному зростанню
попиту на IT-технології, а також євроінтеграції.
Рівень довіри збільшився.
Якщо раніше деякі компанії не могли навіть думати
про те, щоб працювати з Україною, то зараз вони відкриті до цього.
Це сигнал для багатьох компаній,
для багатьох інвесторів, що
країна рухається у правильному напрямку,
і бізнес-енвайронмент тут буде прогресувати.
Утім, на тлі глобального зростання львівської галузі інформаційних технологій
успіх N-iX не видається чимось дивним.
Лише за останній рік у Львові з’явилися
70 нових IT-компаній. Нині їх вже майже 320.
Кількість фахівців також стрімко зростає.
Адже проблем з "відтоком мізків" галузь не має.
Навпаки - програмісти охоче переїжджають до Львова
зі всієї України, зокрема зі столиці.
А деякі - навіть повертаються з-за кордону.
Адже середній дохід львівського айтішника - 1800 доларів.
Завдяки низьким податкам і витратам на життя
в Україні вони можуть дозволити собі більше, ніж колеги в Європі.
Тож, їхати на чужину необхідності немає. Хіба що у відпустку.
У нас дуже комфортні умови для життя.
у нас смачна кава, у нас конкурентні заробітні плати,
що також є дуже важливим.
Заробітна плата львівського IT-спеціаліста абсолютно рівноцінна
заробітній платі у Варшаві чи в Софії.
Також дуже велика перевага Львова - це сполучення.
Близько кордони, аеропорт розвинутий.
На уікенд дуже зручно полетіти
у будь-яке місто Європи, що також приваблює до нас людей.
У 2018 році у Львові працювала
21 тисяча ІТ-спеціалістів.
За прогнозами експертів, до кінця 2019 року
їхня кількість зросте до 24 тисяч.
До того ж, на кожне робоче місце айтішника
з’являється ще 3-4 суміжних. Тобто, в IT-секторі
так чи інакше зайнятий кожен четвертий львів’янин працездатного віку -
це найвищий показник в Україні.
Для міста IT-сектор має стратегічне значення -
поряд з туризмом він став основою економіки Львова.
Міська влада всіляко підтримує галузь
і активно взаємодіє з IT-компаніями.
Вони у Львові не стільки конкурують, як співпрацюють,
навіть об’єдналися в IT-кластер,
щоб ефективніше розвивати галузь.
Директор організації Степан Веселовський раніше сам працював
в Інституті міста при Львівській міськраді.
Ми єдине місто в Україні,
яке за останні три роки створило 12 нових навчальних програм в університетах.
Маючи якісну освіту і маючи хороший бренд на ринку,
як локація, ми спровокували великий
потік людей і бізнесу сюди, які захотіли працювати у Львові.
А для того, щоб ці люди і бізнеси були ефективні,
необхідна якісна інфраструктура.
У співпраці з Львівською міською радою
кластер вже побудував IT House -
єдиний в Україні кооперативний будинок для айтішників,
в якому вони могли купити квартиру за собівартістю.
Ділянку місто надало безкоштовно.
Зараз планується вже другий такий проект.
Але найголовніше - за ініціативою Львівського IT-кластеру
у місті почалося будівництво IT парку -
величезного комплексу на 10 гектарах з офісними приміщеннями
загальною площею майже 100 тисяч квадратних метрів.
Проект для галузі вкрай важливий.
Адже офісів не вистачає вже зараз,
а кількість IT-фахівців у Львові щороку збільшується на чверть.
Представники галузі впевнені: за таких темпів,
якщо буде достатньо офісних приміщень
і не підвищать податки для ФОПів, у Львоа є всі шанси
шанси стати "кремнієвою долиною" Східної Європи.